[Music]
this is star talk neil degrasse tyson
here your personal astrophysicist we've
got a special installment today it's
sort of an update on the coveted 19
virus in particular
omicron
oh my gosh we got oh macron i got chuck
nice co-host here chuck how you doing
man hey neil
you're all right all right
ella macron i mean i i know it's very
serious but
i might i know it's a letter of the
greek alphabet but
the only thing i know about omicron is
omicron persei eight which is that from
star trek okay
some planet and star trek right yes
well neither you nor i have expertise in
this subject and so we found someone who
does and it is dr george yonkopolis who
is president and chief scientist of
regeneron
regeneron a biomedical company actually
right up the street here in tarrytown
new york and we don't normally invite
ceos onto the show because we just don't
because why why would we
but in this particular case george on
campus is a classmate of mine from high
school
and so that's why we have them all that
so that that that legitimizes it i think
doesn't it chuck
yeah oh yeah without a doubt that's the
reason that that that's the reason there
you go so george where are you there you
go thank you welcome to star talk george
thank you jewel thank you george thank
you neo i'm sorry about that
yeah listen that is a sign of true
confidence right there when you when you
enter a show and thank yourself
it's hard for me because you know as as
you guys just heard i'm a classmate in
high school of neil degrasse tyson so
it's i'm living in the shadow forever
[Laughter]
well yeah i don't know what kind of [ __ ]
what the what that shadow looks like
because
we come out of high school you are my
valedictorian right of of that of our
graduating year i graduated some like
300th or something you're valedictorian
and so now you're sort of a billionaire
co-founder of regeneron and so maybe we
do a whole other show on how to become a
billionaire i think that's
get good grades i guess is that where it
starts so george you you are a bio
medical scientist immunology expert
you're an expert and
uh some of the items on your resume or
in your company's resume is that you
developed
the most valuable
mice ever
these are mice that have the exact
immune system of human beings so that
one can test antiviral treatments on
these mice and know it's going to work
with humans i didn't know you could do
that that's a thing you could do invent
a mouse
yeah
except for walt disney except for walt
disney yes yes
yeah mickey mouse might actually be more
valuable if you take that into account
but um you know for movie fans if you
saw i am legend and so forth you
remember um
that will smith was in the basement and
he was you know working with these rats
and he was injecting them well just to
catch everybody up he's a he's a he's a
biologist i guess an immunologist and
there's a virus that basically turned
everybody into zombies who didn't
otherwise kill and he's trying to find
the magic serum for this and he thinks
he's at one point the last person alive
on earth to do so so pick it up from
there
yeah and he's testing at night while
he's fighting the zombies during the day
at night he's in the basement laboratory
injecting
you know rodents with the test serums
and so forth our basic theory was a long
ago
was
if you had any disease any epidemic and
the example i used to give was ebola
and as we know unfortunately if most
people get ebola they're going to die
unfortunately um and rarely as
will smith was in the movie one in a
million or might might survive and that
one in a million would then have the
magic serum that their body made which
was really antibodies to keep them alive
and that was will smith the hero in the
movie his was the one in a million
person who had beaten the virus because
of his own antibodies and what he was
trying to do was clone them out of
himself but cloning antibodies out of a
human is really hard
so we had the idea why why is it really
hard because essentially you have to
almost
you know
kill the human to get all the antibodies
out of the human so we had this idea a
long time ago now was well what if we
put the human immune system into a mouse
and we gave a thousand or ten thousand
mice ebola if one in a thousand or one
in ten thousand mice survived from ebola
they would have beaten it with a human
antibody but we could literally harvest
all the ant bodies out of that one human
mouse we wouldn't have to do these one
at a time experiments that will smith
was doing we could literally take all
the antibodies harvest them all out of
that mouse
and essentially
come up with a cure for ebola which we
actually did we came up with a cure from
ebola by essentially infecting mice
with the equivalent of ebola one of the
mice survived we pulled out the fully
human antibody that that mouse was
making because it had a fully human
immune system grew it up in these
bioreactors outside the body purified it
gave back to humans and we did a trial
with the world health organization the
nih in the congo during the depths of
the
you know epidemic there and it
was a cure for ebola
and and so
wow that's why people were so excited in
the early days of the pandemic before
there was anything else about our
approach and the antibody approach in
particular that we might be able to come
up with antibodies that could attack the
virus and kill it and cure people
so is this all that is
i i just want to say two things one
that is genius absolute genius and two
mice
hate you
actually mice in the wild would just get
swallowed by a bird an owl or something
so maybe the mice in the lab they're
they're they're seeing that they lived a
good life they lived a good life they're
well-fed they lived a good life
right right you guys want to hear
something totally crazy
okay you know many humans are allergic
to cats
right you all know that yeah so why are
they allergic to cats because cats make
an allergen something that we're all
allergic to
so we actually
took a couple thousand mice
and
attacked them and made them allergic to
cats and we got a couple mice that
actually were now resistant they had
beaten the cat allergen
essentially they had
cured themselves of cat allergy and
we've now purified and given it to
humans and actually works against cat
algae and humans so think about it we
first made mice allergic to cats and
then we used the mice to come up with
the cure for cat algae so somehow i
don't know that's somehow related to the
war between the animals and the mice
negotiated the first the first peace
treaty between tom and jerry
so this this fact that we get one in a
thousand or one in a million
uh that's goes beyond clinical trials
you can't test a million people
typically in a clinical trial but we
know am i correct that there were some
people who were found to have a natural
immunity to
the hiv virus is the hiv is that correct
yes that is true
so were those people collected and and
and do a sort of
you know an i am legend scenario with
them
yeah so that's a really interesting
point so with hiv there's two ways that
rare people
can actually become
uh resistant
um and one way is because their bodies
are genetically missing
the receptor for hiv so hiv in order
into cells has to bind to something on
human cells and some human beings are
missing that receptor and these are
people who are rarely resistant they
don't get any infection at all other
people got infected but their bodies
very rarely made what they call a
broadly neutralizing antibody that was
effective and both of those approaches
are being used going forward and have
already in some cases help people they
actually took
the stem cells out of a human being
because the stem cells they're what they
call the blood stem cells or the
hemopoietic stem cells they make your
blood cells including your t cells we
all know that hiv attacks your t cells
so what they did was they took a poor
pain who was suffering from hiv because
the hiv was killing their t cells
and they
took out their stem cells they knocked
out the hiv receptor and then they gave
them the stem cells back
and now
this person's own stem cells were now
engineered genetically engineered to be
resistant to hiv because they no longer
had the receptor and they repopulated
themselves and they were cured of hiv
now that's a very hard treatment to do
to
thousands or hundreds of thousands of
people because that's a genetic
manipulation and a stem cell transplant
but it actually works so you're
absolutely right just like i am legend
there are the rare hiv people who are
immune
via these two different approaches one
is antibodies which is related to what
we're doing for covid and the other is
you know missing the receptor and
they've taken both approaches and
they're trying to use them to to help in
the hiv situation but if i don't have a
receptor it doesn't mean i'm warding off
hiv it means i'm not
affected by it but does that mean i can
still carry it
no well the beauty is
the way we all get infected is just a
few viruses enter into our body and if
the
virus sticks to our cells enters into
them through the receptor and then
replicates makes many many copies of
itself that's how it continues to
survive in our body if it has nothing to
stick to it floats around for a little
while and then it just dies
so the people who don't have the hiv
receptor are not only resistant for
themselves but the virus just naturally
the few viruses that will get into you
die out and you don't make any more the
way you infect somebody else the way
viruses work is they use us as a host
to make many copies of themselves and
then spread themselves out often through
our secretions through our cough and so
forth so if you're not making much virus
you're not going to spread it so those
people are resistant to the virus and
they will never spread it
so this is what they talk about when
they talk about viral load when when it
comes to the spread of covid and there
there are people who have more viral
load at a certain time and so they're
more prone to give
the the disease to somebody else
exactly right so what happens is
we all
catch it from
you know an aerosolized particle a
little droplet of moisture in the air
that somebody has coughed up for example
or by touching a surface that somebody
recently might have rubbed their eyeball
and touched and and now you touched it
so a tiny particle of moisture that has
a few viruses in it we then touch and we
touch one of our own mucous membranes
that one or a few viruses enter into us
that will not do us any harm normally
except that if one of those viruses
sticks to a receptor inside of our body
it invades that cell that's all over the
cell that's all she wrote makes millions
of copies those millions of viruses then
flow out
a while away from that first cell and
they they now affect a million cells and
soon enough a million times a million
becomes a billion and all of a sudden
you are way out of control
um wow actually a million times a
million million times and millions of
trillion just to begin to the 12th
it's an astronomically
astronomically large number so tell me
the difference between
i think i know this but i want to hear
it out of the horse's mouth sorry to
call you a horse in this example but
the
the other companies made
vaccines against covid and you made what
we call monoclonal antibodies against
covid so as i understand it correctly
your treatment is if you got covid
you take your treatment and that helps
you fight it and might even prevent you
from having a hospital visit so you're
not preventing
covet in the first place you're
attacking it after it is manifested do i
understand that correctly
well yes you do but there's other ways
to use antibodies so let's step back for
a second so this is why we need all
these weapons because they do different
things like you just said
what is so let's step back for a second
let's get back to this concept of viral
load the
a few virus particles attack your body
and they soon take over one cell and
then a million cells and now there's an
astronomical amount of virus in your
body
what happens
okay
in the case of
ebola unfortunately the body can't react
fast enough okay because the ebola
replicates so fast and and so destroys
so many cells
that unfortunately invariably as we know
almost all people with ebola will die
okay luckily in the case of covid
it's not as lethal which means the virus
is replicating more slowly so you you
get to these astronomical levels more
slowly and allows in most cases the body
to respond what does that mean the body
responds by making antibodies and unlike
the will smith movie i am legend where
one in a million people made the
response or unlike hiv where only one in
a million make the right response to
covid most humans do make the response
okay and that's why most people do well
and what is that response most people
make their own antibodies
that will cover
their antibodies specific to sticking to
the virus they stick to the surface of
the virus neutralize it keep it from
sticking to anything else itself and the
body just naturally clears it and you're
cured so most people the virus comes on
achieves high levels but it does it
relatively slowly over the course of a
week or so the body responds by making
antibodies that coat the virus
neutralize the virus and resolve the
infection and that's why unlike ebola or
unlike you know the zombie virus that
will smith was trying to beat most
humans beat it
and and so you said it's a it's again
it's a race basically between your your
ability your ability to respond to it
and its ability to multiply
that's exactly right and unfortunately
some people
and we know the people who have risk
factors if you're older your immune
response is not as fast just like
you know we don't run as fast as we did
when we were you know in high school
okay
if you've got certain diseases if you if
you're diabetic if you're
immunocompromised
the definition of immunocompromise is
you can't make antibodies so it's a race
some people are just slower and the
slower you are the more dangerous the
virus becomes for you because it races
to higher numbers before you control it
so you're exactly right it's a race it
between your antibody immune system
and the virus to who takes over so what
does a vaccine do this is why vaccines
are so important
they prepare you they are like a fake
infection the only thing that the
vaccine is doing is it fools your body
to think that you actually have a viral
infection but all you're making through
these mrna vaccines is you make the
so-called spike protein the body reacts
to the spike protein by making
antibodies against it which are
neutralizing to the spike which is
neutralizing to the virus so the vaccine
fools your body into making in advance
before you need them the very antibodies
that would normally make to defeat the
virus but now you're prepared it's like
you've already beaten the virus so the
vaccine will protect the vast majority
of people who get it because now you've
made the antibodies the antibodies that
we we we know can beat many viruses
including this virus that's why vaccines
are so important and this is this
accounts this accounts for the ranking
of who got the vaccine first because
when we only had limited supplies you
gave it to the people who are most at
risk because they would need they would
need the best help otherwise the the
virus takes them out and they've got no
chance
so basically you you have this thing
that happens to you
and the vaccine is not necessarily
fighting the thing
it's kind of like an emergency fund that
when you save money for an emergency
fund if you lose your job you're
prepared for the loss of your job you
got this money in the bank and so now
you can actually ride this thing out
because you're prepared for it and so
yeah everybody's in the back scene it's
really doing that's the antibodies in
the bank right right okay yes it's it's
it's really like soldiers in the
soldiers okay this virus this virus is
ready to invade you know the fortress
okay and if they're and the doors are
open if there's no soldiers who are
gonna shoot you know this the virus
that's trying to invade the the virus is
going to come in and the battle is going
to be in the fortress if you man the
walls of the fortress with soldiers who
are shooting the virus before it comes
in you're prepared so essentially it's
preparing you to ward off the virus so
it will never enter into your body
george i have an idea for you so a new
regeneron
when you have a slow year for business
introduce the regeneron video game
the virus
attacking videogames
here come the antibodies here come the
viruses here come tonight
so monoclonal means what because you
came up with monoclonal antibodies what
does that mean
right so um
what
monoclonal means is that your body
normally in response to a vaccine your
body makes
thousands and thousands of different
antibodies they're all different
only some of them are powerful
neutralizers that do stick and kill the
virus
only a small percentage of all of those
antibodies but the vaccine is good as
making so many antibodies that on
average most people will make good
amounts of neutralizing antibodies what
we did and and in this case
um
we use
our special mouse our magic mouse
to make antibodies uh
when you can't make them in humans like
for example humans don't really it's
very hard to get antibiotics against
ebola in humans so you have to do it in
a mice in the case of covid we use our
mice to make these powerful neutralizing
antibodies but we also you we took them
out of some humans who had beaten the
virus already and we looked both in mice
and man
for the most powerful neutralizing
antibodies so we all make many many
antibodies it's called polyclonal
poly for many clones for individual
antibody clones so in response team or
response to the virus both mice and man
make thousands and thousands of
different antibodies we go into the mice
and men and we find the single best
antibody that's a clone of an antibody
and our cocktail is a mixture of
actually just by accident it could have
been both for meister both from human
but we got a spectacular antibody from a
mouse and we got another spectacular
antibody from a human and until recently
when we put them together those two
monoclonal antibodies so our monocle and
body cocktail is a mix of two monoclonal
antibodies was considered the most
powerful approach for the last year year
and a half now to fight the virus so
it's it's it's the it's the linea and
george antibody the who exactly the
millennium george antibody
of mice and men
oh sorry lenny lenny i'm sorry
sorry john steinbeck okay excuse me okay
the funny thing is uh as you guys may or
may not know i think
neil you actually met him once but uh my
co-founder and uh the president the
other president of regeneron is len
schleifer so it's uh it is sort of like
the book it's the lenny and george show
italy is lenny gosh gosh so we got to
take a quick break but george when we
come back we want to talk about omicron
and why that represents a new challenge
to your entire industry uh in terms of
what methods and tools you might use
to protect us so
right when we return on star talk
we're back star talk
yet another installment of our
discussions about the corona virus
covid19
and in particular we're concerned about
omicron
and in this installment we've got
actually an old friend who happens to be
president of regeneron dr george
yonkopolis and of course we got check
there and we left off
trying to distinguish between why one
would get a vaccine and when one would
get a monoclonal antibody treatment
which was the specialty of regeneron so
so that so i would get a
vaccine before i'm even exposed to
covid but i get a monoclonal antibody
treatment afterwards so why don't i get
the monoclonal antibody treatment even
in advance what's the difference
well that's a great question so
the whole point of the vaccine is to
make your body make antibodies to
protect you against the virus
some people
aren't vaccinated unfortunately or some
people even if they are vaccinated their
body hasn't made good enough antibodies
or some people who are immunocomics
haven't made any antibodies so some
people
either because they're not vaccinated or
they didn't respond well enough to the
vaccine we'll still get sick
for those people we can give them the
monocle and antibody treatment because
what that does is it's like loading them
up literally with a thousand times more
antibodies than you would make in
response to a vaccine and it helps you
beat and control the virus so what we
showed
and in the highest risk people who have
a high chance somewhere on the order of
10 percent of having to be hospitalized
or dying these are the elderly who who
suffer from an assortment of problems
that we reduce the rate of
hospitalization and death by around 70
to 80 percent that is huge because it's
keeping people out of the hospital and
it's saving their lives so you can use
this to treat the people who are getting
sick if they're at high risk
whether they got vaccinated and didn't
respond or whether they never got
vaccinated so uh as you know the white
house just announced there were more
than a couple million people dosed with
this and this has if you do the math it
saved countless lives oh yeah you just
you just represented factor into that
yeah it's it's it's uh what is it twenty
thousand uh no no uh two hundred
thousand ten percent of two million is
200 000. yeah
yeah and so and if we save we saved 78
of those that's that's a that's a big
number
we should have
logistics have prevented us from really
um
we could have treated more we should
have as a society just like we should be
vaccinating more people we should have
treated more people with uh uh with
monoclonal antibiotics but the other and
so this is what the fda has authorized
our antibody treatment for but also a
couple other antibody treatments that
are also very impressive for this
purpose of taking people who are already
sick and keeping them out of hospitals
and keeping them from dying and all of
the monochlorine body treatments are
very impressively effective ours has
been sort of up until now the most
widely used of these treatments and even
it was used by the president was even
used by the president
yes if i remember exactly
so the the other important thing that
we've shown in clinical trials
uh and we have lied for
authorization with the fda and we think
it's very important that they act
quickly on this and allow it is as we
all know now and there's been
you know stories on 60 minutes and and
cnn and so forth okay that despite
vaccination
the immunocompromise are not protected
if anything they get a false sense of
security what does immunocompromise mean
is you're not making antibodies to a
disease but also to a vaccine so those
people
are
unprotected even if they've been boosted
boosted twice it doesn't matter your
body is not making antibodies you get no
protection from the vaccine
unfortunately there's five to ten
million americans like that and so what
we've shown
is that for people who don't have their
own antibodies
we can protect you we can do exactly
what you said neil we can give you the
ant body beforehand in fact we can give
it to you
maybe twice a year or four times a year
and now the antibodies last in your body
for months and they keep you protected
you're as good if not better protected
than a vaccinated person so for the
people the the small percentage i mean
you'd wanna because it's much harder to
make monoclonal antibodies than it is to
make a vaccine so you wanna vaccinate as
many people as you can but there will
always be that five to ten million
americans about five percent of the
population three to five percent of the
population that will just not respond to
the vaccine for them
they are true prisoners of the pandemic
because they can't go out and resume
their lives if if if and many of them
these are people who've had lymphoma or
multiple sclerosis or other these
diseases other cancers that are keeping
their immune system down many of them
know it they're very sophisticated you
know medically speaking they know that
they're not protected and so they're
trapped okay so for these people we have
applied for the fda for authorization
that we could give ours as what's called
a passive vaccine you made a joke about
a horse before
unbelievably unbelievable the first
nobel prize
was awarded in 1896
because some genius guy von bering
realized that if you took a horse that
was immune to diphtheria or to tetanus
you could take out the horse serum
and you could inject it into humans
and now the humans would be protected
from what were at that time scourges and
epidemics of diphtheria and tetanus and
so forth
what was in the horse serum it was ant
bodies so this was called for years for
over a century now it's been called the
passive vaccination
it protects people
who can't or don't have their own
antibodies so there's two purposes of
monoclonal antibodies to treat those who
are already infected load them up with
monoclonal antibodies which will bind
kill the virus and help cure them keep
70 to 80 out of the hospital and from
dying
or and that's authorized that's fda
authorized and what we've applied more
recently for
is to protect the immuno compromise who
are the small percentage of the people
who can't respond to a vaccine this is
why we need all of these we need the
vaccines
but we need these monoclonal antibodies
okay so now you spoke earlier about the
spike protein that gets targeted
so tell me about omicron if it if
somehow it is our current uh arsenal is
not as effective against it is it
because omicron a variant of covid19
does not have a spike protein
yeah spike is a great
word it's a great word for
these
structures that are on the surface of
the virus and they literally what is the
spike it's what digs into the human cell
and allows the virus to burrow into the
human cell it's literally like a spike
that the virus uses to burrow into the
human cell
and
fertilize itself and and and make many
cop plant itself and make many copies um
and what antibodies do is they literally
cover the spike
and so the spike can't dig into the
human cell that's exactly what
antibodies do and that's exactly what
the spike does and what vaccines do is
they make the body make antibodies that
cover the spike and what we did is we
just picked the best of these antibodies
out of mice and man to make a cocktail
to cover the spike and keep it from from
allowing the virus to dig into the human
cells okay
so what's the difference between that
omicron okay this the
the the spike of omicron
has mutated this is
what we always fear whether it's cancer
or whether it's infectious disease that
we've come up with some cure and so
forth but the cancer or the virus
is so smart in terms of the principles
of evolution that it's just selects for
itself
to
mutate so that the antibodies sticking
to the spike where it's stuck mutated
away so our antibodies or so that
antibodies in general whether they're
from vaccines or formical animals might
not stick as well
that's the big fear is we have rarely
seen
certainly not in the history of covet
but rarely seen with viruses that you
get such a
seismic
shift in terms of the number of
mutations
delta was one or two mutations beta was
one or two mutations
omicron is 32
32 mutations in the spike protein it
completely changes the spike protein and
what that has done is it's terrified
everybody
that possibly the antibodies that we
used to
get from vaccines to stick to the spike
or
the antibodies that we've
selected out of mice and man to give to
patients
will no longer stick as well to the
spike it won't cover it up and now the
spike will be able to dig into the human
cells holy thanks
32 mutations it's just
that's insane one that's so the viruses
are super dangerous so chuck the viruses
are even smarter than that because
go ahead here we go they invented humans
and had humans invent airplanes so that
the viruses can go transcontinental
nice
nice i i hear i hear that
they're they're so smart that they're
now getting us to invent spaceships
right
we can carry the viruses to
other planets to mars but first they
first they got us to invent amazon
[Laughter]
so that we could invent the spaceships
to take them to other planets i i was
going to say number one the omicron
sounds super dangerous and that um you
should maybe take action if you haven't
taken action for yourself personally um
you know or is it that
it's such a change that it won't make a
difference is what i hear people saying
no i mean i i unfortunately we don't
know people are scared now you don't
know yet anymore yet
here
yeah
there's reason to be scared we don't
know the full impact of this at this
point
there's reason to have hope and
certainly just like the biopharma
industry you know
fought back you know against the
original virus
many of us have been anticipating this
potential challenge and that this
challenge would go on and on so many of
us
are trying to be prepared for the worst
case scenario so there's reason that
omicron could be
a real challenge it may diminish vaccine
immunity it may diminish the natural
immunity that people get who have been
naturally infected and made their own
antibodies and it might diminish many of
the monoclonal antibody treatments many
of us in the industry have been afraid
that this might be the case and you have
probably heard from you know the vaccine
makers you know such as the pfizers and
the biotechs and the modernist that
they're already planning on coming up
with potential omicron vaccines if we
need them
if we're losing so much immunity from
the original vaccines that within a few
months
they'll be able to have a new version of
the vaccine that will hopefully protect
us against homecoming in the same way
in the same way
like i said there's a few major
companies like us
like astrazeneca
uh and others who have made monoclonal
antibodies and we have certainly been
planning for this contingency so we
already have
thousands of backup antibodies which
we're testing so we don't know
yet for sure though we're worried
whether our current cocktail is going to
lose a lot of activity but we are
worried that it is but we are prepared
in that we've already even put into
clinical trials
new antibodies that we think will be
able to still be effective even in the
fed of omicron so
unfortunately many of us think that this
is going to be a long game a long
challenge the virus is going to have
peaks and valleys and it's going to
go down
and it's in its prevalence and we're
going to feel pretty good for a while
and then a new variant might come along
it might scare us why is it any
different from the the mutations of the
seasonal flu
where each year all the flu changed a
little bit let's get find another
vaccine for it and everybody gets
vaccine every flu people get flu shots
every year so why wouldn't there be a
covet shot every year for example it
may be exactly the same thing the only
difference and the reason why
the flu generally has not shut down
society and covet has shut down society
and why that solution which is i think
maybe where we're ultimately coming to
exactly what you just described
is that we're going to still have to do
something to protect as many people as
possible more so than the flu because
the rate of serious disease is higher
than it is for flu so flu in general
most flus don't have a 10
hospitalization and death rate among the
high risk population so what does that
mean yes we will want to have
regular vaccines okay and in addition we
will also need because
you know with with with the flu vaccine
and so forth um
you know somebody does get the flu we
tolerate the fact that some people
rarely get really sick and we don't
necessarily treat everybody who has the
flu though many of us now think that
it's a worthwhile thing to do so we are
actually developing flu monoclonal
antibodies so if people get the flu and
particularly if they're older and so
forth we want to protect those people
even if their chance of hospitalization
death may only be one percent but with
covet if it's like 10 percent
that's why there's
so much concern so
despite vaccines
if the future state is exactly how you
describe it people will be getting sick
so we will be needing treatments whether
the treatments are combinations of
monoclonal antibodies or now some of
these old pills that people are talking
about we will also because of the high
rate of potential hospitalization and
death we will also continue to need an
alternative to the vaccine the 5 to 10
million americans who will not respond
to any vaccine the immuno-compromised
people so you're absolutely right
and i see it sort of the same way this
is a long
haul it's going to be a constant
challenge it's going to be
you know back in high school you know i
remember my english teacher mrs
zelaznick she talks about man against
machine man against man man against
nature man against virus this is
humanity against the virus this may be
going on against this virus for a while
we're going to have to constantly update
our vaccines we have to constantly
update our monoclonal antibody
treatments and we're going to probably
have to constantly update
oral pills as they come on why because
the virus is smart it's going to mutate
it's going to get on spaceships it's
going to go crazy so so okay with that
with that here's what i got to ask neil
who did you have for english
miss mcgillicuddy no i don't know
just the last thing before we take a
break and we're going to come back and
get questions from our fan base our our
supporters on patreon who were alerted
that you'd be on the show george so we
we look forward to hearing those chuck
has them uh collated over there the uh
just a quick point the
okay if omicron does rise up the fact
that we've all been vaccinated it won't
protect us necessarily from omicron but
it will continue to protect us from the
from the original virus isn't that
correct it wasn't a waste of effort
just be it's not like the whole virus
everywhere mutated is that
one strain of it mutated now they're
both out there isn't that a fair way to
say it
that is a fair way to say it so for
example right now our monoclonal
antibody treatment is fully effective
against every single other variant of
concern that has arisen those will
continue to circulate
and right now omicron is not really
present at high levels so people
obviously should be continuing getting
vaccinated and if they get sick they
should be continuing to get monoclonal
antibody treatments if omacron
yields a huge surge
then unfortunately all of those people
we don't know yet we don't know the data
i'm not saying it will be the case but
the concern is that many of them will
not be protected sufficiently from the
vaccines and maybe not even from some of
these monoclonal antibodies got it got
it let's take a quick break when we come
back we're going to go into a cosmic
queries mode for this episode to get
uh questions from you guys out there
for our special guest today old friend
of mine george ocopolis we'll be right
back
we're back star talk
third and final segment of our one of
our next installments on
the covet 19 virus in particular we're
interested in the omicron
variant which showed up just recently
and we have as our guest george john
kompolis he's president of regeneron
that's not why we have him here well it
is but that's not why i know him i know
him because we were high school
classmates in the bronx at the bronx
high school of science he's my
valedictorian very proud of him and you
did good you you grew up
you all growed up
so george i you're greek you're
culturally greek i mean
so does that mean there were 14 other
strains of coven 19 before we got to
this one which is a special note
yeah they have i don't know whether i
should be offended or not they they
decided that it was wrong to name these
by country of origin but it seems like
nobody was concerned about giving them
greek letters
blame the greeks
i'm just glad
you know the next letter after omicron
is pi
and we got pi in math don't be naming
your viruses after pie just letting you
know okay we're gonna have to talk if
that happens
they've they've skipped a few letters
yeah because i guess other people have
laid plane
to them
and so i don't know i mean i'd have to
go back and think about it but there
have been quite a few
viruses or variants of concern as they
call them um they call you know the
first one was obviously what they call
alpha which was the original you know
virus then there was one of concern
called beta then a gamma and then a
delta um and we sort of skipped a few
and we're at omicron now yeah well
omicron is oh so maybe it's because this
one is oh you know what you know
a lot of people are worried about yeah
this is the os virus
these are these are patreon supporters
who are now only
uh their exclusive access to our cosmic
queries
um format so here you go
so let's jump right to it this is thomas
cochran who says greetings dr tyson
greetings dr yonkopolis and hello dr
chuckles i am a pediatric hematology
oncology fellow physician in kansas city
where i am thrilled dr young kopolis was
able to join this star installment of
star talk uh your work sir on cytokine
traps is fascinating and seems like it
could help reduce the cytokine storms
that are leading to the overwhelming
inflammation and formation of blood
clots that we are seeing in our
pediatric population will we be able to
use this biological technology
specifically for treating patients
infected with covate if so
will we see it in the hospital formulary
um
that is a great question and so what
what uh this question is about obviously
this is a very educated consumer i
assume a lot of your audience is
um a pediatric
hema oncologist fellow in any case um
what he's referring to is the fact that
when
some people get infected they get very
sick and one of the reasons they get
very sick is that their body's immune
system overreacts not in terms of the
antibodies which are a good thing to
make but in terms of they make these
things called cytokines and it results
in a cytokine storm that many of us have
heard about and too much of these are
defense mechanisms that are literally
like bullets that the body sends out to
kill invaders
and when you have too much of them the
bullets actually turn on the host itself
and they can literally like
kill your lovely fire um
friendly fire
friendly fire and and one of the most
important cytokines that has been shown
in this disease is known as
interleukin-6 it's a cytokine and as um
as a as this uh educated consumer
indicated uh we actually have a a number
of approaches but we have an approved
antibody uh that blocks interleukin six
it goes by the brand name of casaro
we've actually done clinical trials as
does roche they have their own
anti-interleukin-6 antibody called
tocilizumab in any case
both of these have now been recommended
by the world health organization
that if people are sick and if you think
they're suffering from cytokine storm
you should give them things like
steroids because steroids calm down
cytokine storms too but they also
recommend that for certain of these
patients they should also get these
cytokine blockers these il-6 blockers so
these are being used um in many settings
for hospitalized patients when the
physicians think they're suffering from
cytokine storms and we are looking at
the potential of further
advancing this approach so antibodies
are specific targeted bullets to fight
um to fight back against the virus
cytokines are the body sort of
non-specific way to protect itself but
it can kill itself by friendly fire and
and we do have uh a drug that is being
used in a space already uh to protect
ourselves against this cytokine storm
you know death by a friendly female it's
something i i don't think of actively
but
you make the stuff in the lab and you
have your consuming base which is the
medical professionals out there in
hospitals with actual patients and so do
you have some medical newsletter or
something that shows up or do you or
does the fda report it or the governor
like how do you get that information out
there
medical education
it's a serious concern and how to do it
and how to optimize it particularly in a
setting of a pandemic imagine and we
were working hand-in-hand with them
imagine the thousands of frontline
workers they're they're dealing
literally they're in a war zone uh at
least as you guys remember because you
were like us in the epicenter of it back
in march of 2020 okay they were just
trying to keep people alive as best as
they could and you're expecting them to
like learn a whole new field right right
while they're on the front lines of a
war
it's very very challenging very very
difficult and this is why we're we count
we count in many cases on our government
leaders um you know people like you know
dr tony fauci and others while they're
educating the public
they also have you know doctors out
there who can listen with a little bit
more you know sophistication and
knowledge and so it's it's very
important to try to communicate these
complex uh issues because even to
doctors especially those who might have
been trained before monoclonal ambition
is a relatively recent treatment okay
mrna vaccines are also brand new so
communicating how doctors should use
them how to combine them in their
armamentarium to [ __ ] against the
virus it's not easy and unfortunately
you know
you can't criticize anybody really
because it was a war really yeah it was
a fog of war the fog of war when
nobody knows what's going on we could
have all done better we could have done
better
the communicators could have been on
better you know the government could
have done better like i said i mean it's
great that we treated over two million
people uh with our monoclonal antibody
treatments and saved probably hundreds
of thousands of people okay but we could
have probably saved more and hopefully
we will do better going forward because
as we've talked about you know
unfortunately this virus may be with us
for a while especially now with omicron
and so hopefully we will we will
continue to learn how to better
communicate how to get doctors the
information they need even when they're
you know in the fog of war you know
chuck i keep thinking of the video game
here you know
a new uh
new vaccine is produced but their
distribution channels are shut down oh
go back some spaces or whatever i don't
know
all the factors
during the pandemic you know my kids
were home you know from school obviously
because everything was shut down
and they're showing me there's there are
internet games there are viral games
that have gone viral now about beating
it and the tools at your disposals or
vaccines monoclonal antibodies okay so
there is there is something going on
okay um
there are viral games all right time for
a couple more questions
here we go matthew dean says this
viruses mutate hey come on that's what
they do should we be treating every
newfound mutation with the significance
by blasting it all over the media will
the hype over mutation cause the public
to ignore future warnings of mutation of
course there's the old adage what
doesn't kill you mutates and tries again
and then k travosky
which is a very funny saying k
actually adds on to this what needs to
happen for the socio-political and
public health standpoint uh before we
can calm people down with respect to
these new variants
so one does it make people ignore what
they have to do is is it a chicken list
how do we calm it down chicken little
calm down
well i think that
you know i'm one for
transparency and trying to get as much
information out there i think that there
is real reason to be concerned
and we should all try to prepare as much
as possible i hope that somehow we can
prevent panic from setting in but of
course we also don't want people to
become complacent because oh yeah it's
just another another mutation i do think
i hope that the people who need to take
this seriously in terms of figuring out
how we're all going to fight back you
know people like all the people at
regeneron who are already working on the
next monoclonal ant body if we are going
to need it or the people you know at the
vaccine companies who are working night
and day right now to come up with the
next version of vaccine in case we need
it against omicron i think that it is
important so all of us who who are in
the front lines whether we're the ones
who are dealing with the patients or the
ones who are coming up with the with the
bio weapons to fight back we need this
information we need to share it we need
to communicate it and i hope i hope
people there are people like you guys i
mean it's such an important function
to correctly get the information out
there and prepare the people so that
they they can do what's right and they
can understand what's right it's a viral
literacy it's a virus we think of
mathematical illiteracy
there's a viral illiteracy that needs to
be combated as well as the virus itself
apparently i think it's so critical you
don't want people going off and talking
about crazy things we need education
here i'm one who believes that an
educated public an educated consumer
like some of the folks who are asking
your questions i mean they can they can
be an asset to all of our efforts to
fight back it can prevent panic and and
we can all do better because like i said
we all have to do better yeah cool very
cool like chuck maybe time for two more
we'll do it do them quick go
do them quick here we go amy a says this
and kevin de sommelier has the same
question so guys i'm mentioning both of
you have a simile in there you have a
salmon yay that's kevin
yeah i wonder what he drinks too i hope
it's my favorite chateau nifta pop um
okay if this if this variant is less
deadly but more transmissible will it
take over and out compete the other
variants if this is the case then maybe
covid will drop down to the status of
something like the flu oh interesting
yeah do we know the lethality of operon
yet
that is a hope this is why we're all
working so hard to better understand
omicron it may be exactly like
that listener just
just suggested that it may be more
transmissible it may actually spread
faster but if it's much less lethal and
there's some reason to hope or believe
that this in general happens to viruses
they don't select to be more lethal they
select to spread faster
and so by selection by the evolution
that selects for spreading faster they
may actually lose some of that early
lethality let us hope that that's the
case you know we will learn this is why
it's so important for all of us now to
have our antennae up all of us who who
track all this information we're going
to learn about this in the coming weeks
and we may get some bad news that oh
maybe this virus is much more infectious
and much more transmissible maybe we'll
get some bad news that maybe the
vaccines don't protect as well against
us then maybe some of the monoclonal
antibodies don't don't don't deal with
it as well but maybe we'll get some good
news like this listener suggests that
that maybe it'll be a much milder
disease so this is why there's you know
we shouldn't be panicking we should be
trying to understand as much as we can
right now to understand what we have to
do to fight back and george there's this
interesting fact that
correct me if i'm wrong the more lethal
a virus is the less of a chance it has
to spread because if it kills you before
you cross the street you couldn't spread
it against into the people who you were
going to meet in the park because you
died on your way there
so that highly lethal diseases
have working against them their
inability to spread for that reason is
that am i correct killing your
supporters
yes it's that's exactly right i mean
it's it's it's all you have to do is
think about evolution and how it would
work okay it's a combination of it's not
only how lethal it is but if it
hits you and you become symptomatic
right away that's why ebola
thank god
does not spread that much because people
get sick very quickly and when you see i
i mean i hate to put it this way but
blood coming out of everything from
people people avoid them okay they've
liked the plague okay so it's a
combination of how fast you get sick the
worst kind of situation and this is one
of the reasons why covet you know has
probably spread so fast is there's a lot
of people who are asymptomatic
and so they're like typhoid mary's
they're spreading the disease and there
are a lot of people who do really well
and you don't even know it and they're
they're they're spreading the disease so
that's one of the reasons it has spread
because there's a lot of people for whom
the diseases is uneventful and in the
early days you know they might have had
a little sniffle or something they're
still going to work and they're
spreading it okay so
the disease loves that the disease loves
that right
exactly so so
there's nuances on it but it's pretty
much like you say i mean the sicker
somebody gets the faster they get they
get sick the more we know as humans
throughout time before we avoid those
people okay and and the spread is slow
down george we got to call it quits
there this has been a highly
illuminating and fascinating
conversation and uh i'm just glad to be
i need to remind her every now and then
that you're out there because you're
you're i feel
kinship with you for having had shared
teachers and classroom schedules and
and
handball in the yard and
it's just great to see what's happened
in your life in your career and
you're doing right by civilization so
thank you for existing thank you for
being my valedictorian uh
my graduating year
and it was just great to have you here
well thanks for having me and thank you
for being
everyone's including my kids favorite
scientists okay
and and chuck is their favorite comedian
for sure is that right yeah yeah sure
let's go absolutely go ahead i'll take
listen i'll take the charity guys i'll
take it
all right everybody this has been star
talk yet another covid installment this
time trying to get a handle on the
omicron variant i'm neil degrasse tyson
your personal astrophysicist as always
[Music]
you